as other businesses in nevada continue
to open osha officials are making sure
they're following health and safety
rules 8 news now reporter kate houston
is live in the newsroom tonight with the
latest round of compliance checks
kate yes sasha this week nevada osha
officials conducted some new compliance
checks
as well as some follow-ups and these are
to make sure businesses are following
health and safety measures
such as requiring masks and social
distancing now on thursday and friday of
this week
osha officials did 187 new compliance
checks
they focused on large and small
businesses such as restaurants
retail outlets and aquatic facilities
overall 87 percent of those
establishments across the state
were compliant now on your screen you
can see a breakdown of these numbers
all of the grocery stores observed were
compliant meanwhile pools were 75
percent compliant
now on thursday osha officials also did
some follow-up checks
100 percent of the 18 businesses visited
are now compliant with health and safety
measures
overall 74 follow-up visits have been
conducted
only six businesses were still
non-compliant
investigations are being opened at those
locations which could lead to citations
since mid-march osha has issued 98
citations
54 of those citations were issued in las
vegas
with an average penalty of 5 800 dollars
more follow-up visits will happen next
week those will be in areas where large
groups of people congregate
and at establishments where initial
compliance was low
now since these observations began more
than 1700 businesses have been surveyed
statewide 80 percent of them have been
compliant back to you sasha